yo between the three y'all I'm not sure
there's an artist that you guys haven't
worked with obviously you've worked with
Pac before you've worked with Hove
biggie I mean we go on and on I mean
Cube [ __ ] I was just listening to uh the
grand finale on the little John on the
east side Boys album and I was like I
forgot Cube was on this [ __ ] and I was
working out is there for each of you
guys is there a feature that has not
happened yet that just for whatever
reason the planets didn't align and you
didn't you don't have a song with them
yet
um I would say uh Jay-Z Nas
a Q-tip
krs-1 Missy
um
who else I love to do a song with Eminem
people yeah
I love Trick Daddy he's he's ready too
yeah and also and like I said I wanted
to just address the m m situation a lot
of his fans thought that I was dissing
him no I can never do that he's one of
the greatest MCS that ever did and got
away with it you understand me do his
job right
but I was dating somebody had asked me
um who would win in a versus battle
between Eminem and Busta Rhyme and I
said Busta Rhyme but versus this because
versus just like
performance yeah that's all I'm saying I
wasn't knocking uh
and he got a lot of hits so you know
he'll get the party going live it's
crazy like live bust is like it's like
him Tech N9 and like I don't know that's
all that's all I meant a lot of sweat
yeah that's what I meant I wasn't trying
I didn't I would never dis Eminem he one
of the greats if not I went to a bunch
of show and he called me on stage and
hugged me I'm still mad you guys a sweat
Hood he just hugged me
his energy his gen his energy is
incredible he's a great guy he just
drenched me
yeah we had a great verses right which
is amazing you were [ __ ]
I was on Mango Scotto drinking out the
bottle nobody has decided to have fun
like we did nobody it was my brother it
was the funnest doing this with my
brother man everybody got this different
energy it was the funnest to watch
uh I really really enjoyed their verses